now this is the story all about how I
made my second short film offline let's
talk about it first I wrote it is what
I'd like to say but the majority of the
writing credit needs to go to my
co-writer Alan Flanagan pictured here
having his makeup done me and Alan did
outline the story together but the
majority of the actual typing was done
by him mostly I just sat back and gave
him lots of notes next I found myself a
producer is what I would love to say if
you don't know the producer is basically
the person who makes the film something
that you can watch as opposed to
something that just exists in my head I
say producer this is what I want this is
my vision they then either go and get me
what I want or they tell me that I don't
have enough money to do what I want so
please think of something else you can't
produce a film without a producer so you
can imagine that if hypothetically
speaking you were to have three
different producers drop out of your
film in succession even if it was four
perfectly understandable reasons it
still might cause you just a little bit
of stress fortunately for me eventually
I found Emily who along with the team at
Kent snake film came the producer that
didn't quit on me together they
basically saved my movie next I had to
cast the film although not just with my
YouTube friends like I did on the T
Chronicles but this time by doing actual
auditions ultimately I ended up picking
the people who not only seemed like they
fit their roles but also very
importantly to me I chose the people who
seemed like they'd be the nicest to work
with and then we filmed it which you
might expect to be the most stressful
part of all but surprisingly although it
was really really challenging at times
it was also just really really fun I
gave myself a much smaller role in this
film so that I could focus more on
directing and for the first time ever I
directed a film all by myself well done
charlie on the T Chronicles I directed
alongside Kai and so I could always
afford to go to him if I wasn't exactly
sure what to do but on offline I kind of
had to learn to trust my instincts a
little more and due to nervousness I
also did way more planning with it's
film in advance and I kept a binder with
me at all times with my scripts and shot
lists and blocking in it which basically
became my safety blanket in place of not
having a Cayenne with me I'm watching
the footage of me directing back I've
also realized that I seem to be kind of
a weird director I get so insanely
focused on what it is I'm doing that I
have absolutely no idea how I'm coming
across to other people to the point
where you can just watch me mouth the
lines of the actors as they perform
Hunter needless to say though this film
would not have been the pleasant
experience to make if it wasn't for all
of the awesome people who helped me make
it
Kieran's mark is all over this thing as
per normal Jamie did a kick-ass job as
the assistant director keeping us all on
time the odds apartment put in an insane
amount of detail some of which didn't
even make it onto the screen the cast
was talented and lovely as I hope they
would be the list this goes on you guys
are pretty great and lastly I edited the
film very very slowly the truth is that
I hated editing this film when I got
home and looked at the footage that I
had and tried to put something together
I just didn't think it was any good and
so I did the worst possible thing you
can do when you're scared I ran away and
I hoped the film would edit itself
somehow finally after it start to become
a running joke among my friends that I
was never going to finish my film I put
together a rough cut showed it to them
they liked it they gave me some notes I
took them I worked on it some more until
I liked it too and then that was it then
you watched it
all in all I'm very happy that I pushed
myself more on this film technically I
do think offline is more accomplished
than the T Chronicles and I definitely
feel like I'm a better filmmaker for
having made it but as I said when I
finished my last film I still hope I can
do better so three more films to go oh
god you've just had the almost
imponderable joy of watching Charlie is
so cool like which makes you like cool
[Music]